i have to say something about you
because where are you going to me i just
admire you so and i'm so proud of you i
feel like
proud like a mama so
good on you i think this is incredible
i think it's incredible
happy for you
and you have been someone that's like
been one of my favorite actresses i know
you know better things has really
come to that forefront because it's
current and it's been the last several
years of your life and you've done
things with it that like
wasn't happening on shows i mean you
look at the way that scene is shot
like that is not your typical
television show that is art there's
movement there's
really interesting edits there's
musicality to it literally and
metaphorically and you're you're looking
at people so the scene is with two
people that you're never going to see
again but it's really about the
interactions that my character's name is
sam
and um what other people bring into your
life and
you know it's it's really about the
village and i'm a single mom i have
three daughters and
uh there was a certain point that i
finally went
okay so after i have three it's just a
whirlwind
now it's time to bring your friends in
and then you feel what the village is
like and it's something that um we do in
my show where
you you push the boundaries and you know
with um with the girls and sam
they they need to know
that they could do the worst thing and
that she's still going to be there yes
but there's a point
where you get to
an age where the kids grow up and
there's a level of respect and so
there's just these many kind of
gradations of
family and growth and you know this has
been five seasons and i started the show
seven years ago
and two all of my kids were living at
home then i know it and if this show is
fun
this show is so
accoladed
why
because you are the mother of three
daughters yeah how did you look at your
life
through a lens of i could tell the story
of this
yeah it was uh i think it was
when uh my mother was driving me crazy
which was
always
and uh
she'd just be telling stories or
whatever and
you know i found myself like i finally
looked at my mother one day and i just
went oh she's funny
this is funny
and so if you change the perspective of
how you receive the information and i
have this saying which is bad for my
life good for my show
so um it's um oh my god that is a
whoa yes i just appreciate how you can
bring heart and humor and keep it real
for all of us moms out there
who are so hard on ourselves already as
if we needed more pressure yeah um so
thank you for doing that
like
i really appreciate that it's so
awesome
i want
nothing more in this world than to keep
it real but keep aspirations high we all
gotta aspire yeah pamela will you play
um as a finisher uh my favorite game
with me the final five oh yes
[Applause]
all right i talked with rosie perez
about hickeys hickeys yay or nay
oh
uh
yes very much so
[Applause]
um okay favorite curse word
oh man it's like we're fully in actor's
studio right now we're allowed to lipton
is here
[Applause]
[Laughter]
your favorite late night snack you're at
the fridge and you're going for it uh
persian cucumbers with lemon and sea
salt flakes that's not the naughtiest
i've ever heard but it's delicious
sliced um okay your favorite chore
cooking the last google search you did
um the drew barrymore show really
awesome i love that
oh pamela
how does it feel
tonight is the night you close out this
profound chapter in your life
and for all of those viewers who have
loved and been loyal to the show how
does it feel
i i feel so grateful and i'm really
really happy i i have this this
beautiful uh
five seasons of
uh a story of uh a family
and their friends and the village and
it's it's
it's magical it's just i i feel i'm i'm
i'm floating on air
well thank you for putting it out into
the world thank you so much
a serious finale of better things airs
tonight on fx in the streaming on hulu
[Music]